[Música]
esta mañana frente a las costas gabosas
también
Acompaña a un grupo de turistas
parisinos en busca de ballenas jorobadas
[Música]
tardaron menos de 10 minutos en
encontrarlas la primera está muy cerca a
pocos metros del barco
es tan impresionante que la verdad ni
siquiera puedo caer en cuenta que las
estoy viendo
que están alrededor nuestro es
absolutamente increíble
son majestuosas tan inmensas y me
parecen que se desplazan con mucha
gracia
madre e hijo habían esperado este viaje
Desde hacía años
y el espectáculo está lejos de terminar
una vida no alcanza para verlo todo
es un camión de 30 toneladas que sale
del agua y vuelve a caer con un ruido
ensordecedor
siempre me dan escalofríos nunca deja de
ser nuevo
para tener la experiencia completa y
aprovechando que el mar está en calma
el guía Franco gabonés incluso Deja que
sus clientes naden con las ballenas
Recuerden que es un animal salvaje que
tiene un comportamiento imprevisible
cuando estén en el agua eviten los
gestos bruscos Déjense llevar
los más valientes se lanzan al agua y
aquí están junto a uno de los mamíferos
más grandes del mundo
15 metros de largo con un canto
envolvente
[Música]
Pero dentro cuando se sumerge hay que
fijarse rápido porque se debe pasar la
cola y después ya se han ido
cada verano gabón recibe una de las
mayores poblaciones de ballenas
jorobadas
en junio miles salen del Océano
Antártico y se dirigen hacia las cálidas
aguas de las costas africanas los
cetáceos se instalan frente a Madagascar
y gabón para reproducirse y se vuelven a
ir en septiembre con sus crías
para la conservación de estos animales
el país se estableció 20 zonas marítimas
protegidas por ecoguardias
es el responsable del parque marítimo
más grande en el sur de gabón
vamos a bordear las costas hasta la
frontera congoleña
tú vigilas al frente
Regis la derecha
la misión del día comprobar que no hay
intrusos en la reserva
anota el punto GPS bueno
para proteger a un animal lo primero es
saber cuántos son si conocemos la
cantidad de especímenes que tenemos en
nuestras áreas protegidas es más fácil
tomar medidas
gracias a los datos recolectados las
autoridades podrán mejorar su programa
de protección de la fauna Marina
estas patrullas también permiten
analizar el comportamiento de las
ballenas
que nunca terminan de sorprenderlos
parece que hubiera pasado por debajo de
la lancha pasó debajo de la lancha ahí
está ahí está durante varios minutos el
animal da vueltas alrededor del barco
saca su cabeza del agua y
Posada
Por eso me encanta mi trabajo
para que el espectáculo pueda continuar
gabón estableció como objetivo agrandar
las reservas marítimas y proteger
integralmente el 30% de sus aguas a lo
largo de los próximos 10 años
[Música]